[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA
Qatar 2022 a continuación nuestros
titulares
Victoria contundente de Argentina frente
a Croacia que la lleva en volandas hasta
la final del mundial un gran Leo Messi
con una jugada maestra en el tercer gol
consciente de la oportunidad histórica y
el joven Julián Álvarez fueron claves en
la victoria de Argentina
Lionel Messi precisamente el Astro
argentino empató Este martes al alemán
lotter majoys con como jugador con más
partidos jugados en un mundial de fútbol
un total de 25 vatios también a Gabriel
Bautista como máximo goleador argentino
en los mundiales buscará ahora su primer
título
para conocer al segundo finalista de
este torneo aún debemos esperar un día
más hoy Francia y Marruecos llevaron a
cabo sus últimos entrenamientos antes
del partido que los enfrentará el
miércoles aquí mi entrenó por separado
como Marruecos
para analizar el desarrollo de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio saso periodista de la emisora
Blu radio de Colombia bienvenido de
nuevo Octavio Hola Rodrigo un gusto
saludarte como siempre Un gusto también
y vamos a ir ahora también a saludar a
nuestra enviada especial a Qatar a
Natalia Ruiz que nos va a traer las
últimas noticias de lo que ha vivido en
ese estadio en el que se ha jugado el
partido de Argentina bienvenida Natalia
Hola Buenas noches buenas noches vamos a
empezar primero antes de venir con
vosotros dos nos vamos a ir hasta
Argentina porque allí en la capital en
Buenos Aires está nuestro corresponsal
natalio cosoy recordemos que es el nuevo
finalista del mundial de fútbol con un
nombre propio muy claro Lionel Messi que
hoy demostró que aún tiene mucho por
demostrar a sus 35 años ahora deberán
esperar al partido de mañana entre
Francia y Marruecos para conocer a su
rival el último que separa a Lionel
Messi de su anhelado título de campeón
del mundo como decía Vamos hasta Buenos
Aires con nuestro corresponsal natalio
coso y natalio como se está viviendo
esta locura futbolística de la
albiceleste allí en la capital
Cómo explicarlo tienen las inmediaciones
del obelisco el epicentro de la ciudad
de Buenos Aires una zona de protestas y
celebraciones hoy de celebración cuando
venía para acá hablaba con la gente de
la producción y me decía Busquemos un
lugar donde haya festejos bueno había
festejos en todo el camino dos
kilómetros recorridos de festejos y se
puede ver detrás mío la gente todavía
llegando al obelisco a celebrar estamos
hablando que el partido terminó hace más
de una hora y la gente sigue llegando
para celebrar en este lugar de la ciudad
por qué tanto festejos bueno primero de
Argentina llega a la final pasando una
semifinal que se creía difícil y
Argentina
muy muy contundente Pero además también
porque hay mucha expectativa de que este
puede ser el tercer mundial que gana
Argentina y sobre todo el primero que
pueda lograr Lionel Messi que es la
figura la figura esencial de esta
selección y que esta gente evidentemente
aquí en esta gente evidentemente le
tiene muchísimo cariño Pues qué envidia
desde luego natalio seguro que tú
también tendrás tiempo para celebrar
esta Victoria y Quién ha podido ver
también el ambiente que había en el
estadio es como avanzaba antes nuestra
mirada especial Natalia Ruiz Natalia
había muchos aficionados argentinos allí
en Qatar en esta jornada
Así es Rodrigo pues esto fue Full House
digamos aquí en este estadio de hecho ya
sobre el segundo tiempo anunciaron que
el estadio estaba completamente lleno la
primera vez que hacen este anuncio en
este mundial o en todo caso en los la
mayoría en todos los partidos en los que
hemos podido estar y esto a pesar de que
había varias varias sillas que se veían
un poco vacías Pero por supuesto pues la
hinchada de la albiceleste estuvo
presente como ha estado presente en cada
uno de los partidos siempre con sus
cantos o sea siempre alentando y pues
siempre haciéndose sentir no
prácticamente pues son ese jugador
número 12 que ha venido
jugando importante en cada uno de los de
los equipos y que se siente además esa
importante conexión que tiene con los
jugadores de como los jugadores van
hasta esa hinchada para para para
celebrar con ellos cada uno de los
triunfos cada uno de los goles Hoy hubo
unas celebraciones muy bonitas en cada
uno de los goles con esa hinchada allí
Así que efectivamente pues una vez más
tuvimos un estadio completamente
albiceleste Natalia nos hablas de los
goles Así que vamos precisamente a
hablar de los futbolístico que hemos
visto en este campo
Así es pues hay tres goles que se han
marcado hoy tres muy buenos goles hay
que hablar de ese penalti que llega ya
sobre el minuto 34 con esa falta del
ivacubiche de la Arquero croata un
poquito se discutió un poco en las
gradas y en realidad era pena el tío No
pero luego ya habiendo la repetición se
ve efectivamente que si hay una falta de
El Arquero un excelente cobro por parte
de Leonel Messi ante un Arquero que ha
sido absolutamente Fantástico a lo largo
de este mundial que ya también ha tapado
varios penales y luego llegaría ese
segundo gol que en una jugada que parte
de otamendi en el fondo de la cancha y
finalmente pues es Julián Álvarez quien
consigue ese gol eso hay cinco minutos
entre el primer y el segundo gol y ya
vendría el tercero en el minuto 69 que
es el golazo quizás un gol que ya todo
el mundo habla de de histórico algo que
queda digamos para enmarcar por parte de
Leo Messi a pesar de que el gol pues
finalmente sea una vez más Julián
Álvarez quien lo convierte pues la
jugada es toda de Messi allí en el área
de
la línea ya de fondo y deja a guardiol
podríamos decirlo pintado ahí en la
cancha lo deja lo deja un poco loco se
voltea hace de todo Leo Messi en esa
jugada para poder dar ese pase magistral
a Julián Álvarez Y pues de esta manera
que Argentina consigue esta Victoria
tres goles por cero y finalmente Croacia
que tuvo muy pocas ocasiones de poder
acercarse al al arco de dibu Martínez
pues Natalia Muchas gracias por este
repaso mañana estaremos también contigo
y con el otro enviado especial Juan
pupiales porque estoy seguro de que
estaréis atentos a todo lo que pase en
ese Francia Marruecos gracias Natalia de
nuevo y vengo ya con Octavio aquí a este
estudio de France 24 Octavio Yo sé que a
ti también te gusta mucho las bici
Celeste y que también habrás celebrado y
cómo no vamos a hablar de algo que ya
nos decía Natalia el encuentro de Leo
Messi y de Julián Álvarez Las dos
grandes figuras de este partido un Leo
Messi que ha salido desde un principio
quizás consciente de que este es un
mundial de que tiene que dar el todo por
el todo para levantar ese ansiado título
ha marcado un penalti del libro también
quizás con polémica por la jugada y
después la jugada maestra de ese tercer
gol de Argentina que estamos viendo en
Leo Messi que es tan importante
realmente para Argentina esta figura sí
ha sido formidal el partido de hoy
Rodrigo Porque además él en un principio
del del juego sintió una molestia en el
isquiotibial empezó a copiar y todo el
mundo empezaba a preocuparse no solo
porque por este partido sino porque lo
que podía pasar en función del
rendimiento de Argentina a medida que
fue pasando los minutos se asentó se
quedó tranquilo se puso a jugar en
función del equipo y empezó a generar
esas posibilidades de espacio para una
Argentina que fue de menos a más no hay
que olvidarse que Croacia dominó la
primera parte del del partido pero aún
así lo que está haciendo Messi y lo que
me preguntaba Rodrigo a lo largo de esta
copa del mundo y precisamente en este
partido tiene que que tiene que ser
evidentemente tarea de estudio Messi
sabe su edad sabe sus condiciones y a
pesar de eso tiene la experiencia y la
capacidad porque es uno de los grandes
jugadores de la historia de saber cuándo
aprieta cuando pausa cuando domina el
partido cuando corre y eso no los mostró
no son la jugada del penal sino luego en
esa jugada que terminó marcando la
diferencia para para el tres a cero ha
sido realmente muy bueno sacrificio ida
y vuelta defiende ayuda a sus compañeros
y luego termina generando incluso goles
a Juliana Álvarez que ha tenido el día
de de de sus sueños no hace muy pocos
meses se tomaba una foto como como
hincha de Messi y hoy aparece con él
marcando los mejores goles de su carrera
pues es que precisamente de él quería
hablar porque hasta hace poco todavía
jugaba en la liga Argentina en River
Plate si no me confundo y ya antes de
acabar la temporada pasada lo fichó el
Manchester City que lo dejó acabar la
liga Argentina
que estamos viendo que qué potencial
tiene Julián Álvarez que ha hecho en
este en este torneo y desde luego Hasta
dónde puede llegar este jugador no una
historia muy linda la de Julián Álvarez
que pudo haber jugado en Boca en el
principio de su carrera que se fue a
probar ahí que termina jugando en river
que lo pudo haber hecho Incluso en el
Real Madrid porque se fue a probar al
fútbol español que cuando era pequeño le
pidió una foto a Messi porque ya ya era
su ídolo y que hoy Rueda en redes
sociales una foto de hoy con Messi tiene
que ser genial esa foto y luego aparece
aquí estamos hablando de un jugador
fuera de serie Rodrigo porque no
cualquiera se lo lleva el Manchester
City a la edad de Juliana Álvarez no
cualquiera tiene los elogios de Marcelo
Gallardo el mejor técnico de
latinoamérica seguro y no cualquiera se
lleva los elogios de Guardiola Entonces
él estaba en duda porque no se sabía si
iba a tener un papel
ejecutante en el mundial se iba a tener
titularidad en el mundial y aprovechó
ese despiste entre comillas de lautaro
Martínez para colarse Y ser sin el
delantero titular de escalón y hoy lo
está demostrando tiene una velocidad de
un Sprint una capacidad goleador
importante aprovechó la jugada del penal
aprovechó el gol y luego estaba
perfectamente ubicado para recibir la
pelota de Lionel Messi y marcar el el
tercero es muy bueno lo desvían Álvarez
tiene esa esa chispa de la de la
juventud que que le da la posibilidad de
de hoy estar viviendo seguramente el
momento de sus sueños y sabe leer porque
la jugada de Messi era espectacular Pero
tenía que estar allí Julián Álvarez para
rematar vamos a hablar de otro nombre
que ha salido aquí en este comentario es
el técnico Lionel scaloni ayer mismo
hablabas en este programa que una de sus
fortalezas era que estaba Sabiendo
llevar la táctica del equipo a cada
encuentro acomodarla cada encuentro hoy
Parece que ha vuelto a acertar por
supuesto y hoy lo hizo con los cambios
Me parece que hoy movió el equipo
perfectamente bien entendió cuando debía
sacarle a Rodrigo de Paul que sigue con
molestias que sigue tocado entendió
cuando darle posibilidades incluso a
jugadores que no han jugado en el
mundial como el caso de Paulo dybala y y
de foit empezó a mover algunas cosas en
la mitad y lo otro es lo que hablábamos
Ayer todos los partidos de Argentina han
sido diferentes hoy jugó con esos cinco
en el fondo sin Lisandro Martínez pero
dándole luego la posibilidad a Lisandro
de de jugar y haciendo que el equipo se
fuese cohesionando a medida que pasaban
los minutos parecía que Croacia le iba a
quitar la pelota y escalón y fue paso a
paso haciendo eso cuando yo veo el banco
de suplentes de Argentina Rodrigo
Primero me siento cada vez mayor porque
cuando veo a scaloni a aimar a Samuel a
Roberto Ayala entiendo que pasa el
tiempo pero también entiendo que ellos
cuatro que fueron parte fundamental de
la historia de la Selección Argentina
hoy lo deben estar disfrutando al máximo
porque están viviendo la posibilidad que
ellos no tuvieron como jugador de llegar
a una final del mundo No fíjate que
hasta yo me acuerdo de esos jugadores en
el campo todavía vamos a volver un
momento acatar con nuestra enviada
especial Natalia porque le quiero
preguntar a Natalia cómo ha vivido allí
la hinchada ya nos ha hablado de cómo se
ha sentido dentro del campo pero Qué
comentan los aficionados argentinos en
Qatar porque recordemos que Argentina
empezó perdiendo contra Arabia Saudita
Cómo ha sido el cambio en esta hinchada
Argentina me imagino que ahora mismo se
verán como casi campeones del mundo
Así es pues es bien posible Rodrigo bien
los conocemos pero efectivamente pues
está hinchada en realidad Nunca ha
dejado de estar ahí acompañando a su
equipo a pesar de esos momentos
difíciles a pesar de ese partido ante
Arabia Saudita que pues finalmente dejó
esa sorpresa de cómo Argentina venía a
perder quizás con el el rival que era
menos fuerte en esa fase de grupos de
hecho hace unos instantes Lionel Messi
en la conferencia de prensa estaba le
preguntaron acerca de este partido de
que había hecho Argentina además para
poder digamos cambiar el chip y que el
equipo no se quedara finalmente con esa
derrota en mente y pudiera salir
adelante y él decía que finalmente pues
era todo este trabajo de grupo que han
venido realizando para poder finalmente
salir adelante en todo esto así que los
hinchas siguen aquí siguen todavía con
mucha más fuerza la digamos la
celebración por no decir la rumba va a
ser bastante fuerte del día de hoy
todavía hay muchísimos hinchas alrededor
de este estadio que están pues
continuando cantando todos estos de
canciones que normalmente escuchamos en
cada uno de los partidos en los
banderazos que han realizado en el
centro de doja y pues seguramente
vendrán con mucha más fuerza esperando
además saber cuál va a ser el rival de
Argentina este próximo domingo ahí en
esa final pues desde luego Natalia nunca
dejaron de creer yo todavía recuerdo en
ese primer partido como pudisteis
entrevistar algunos aficionados
argentinos y decían eso que era solo un
fallo antes de que la selección
albiceleste comenzará a rodar allí en
Qatar vamos a seguir porque ya
anunciábamos al inicio de este programa
que el otro finalista de este mundial no
se conocerá esta mañana será un partido
inédito entre Francia y Marruecos
recordemos Marruecos la primera
selección africana en llegar a unas
elecciones del mundial un partido
caliente por la historia que une además
ambos países y hoy hemos equipos
realizaron sus últimos entrenamientos
hubo también rueda de prensa vamos a
volver con Natalia hasta Qatar porque
ella nos puede contar más de lo que pasó
en esa rueda de prensa porque creo que
habló el entrenador francés de diez de
sham
y disposición hablo como bien lo viene
haciendo antes de cada partido con
muchísimas preguntas que le le hacen al
respecto de de Marruecos él ha querido
decir que Marruecos no está aquí por
porque sea un azar efectivamente se ha
hablado mucho de este equipo dirigido
por vales como el equipo que que era la
sorpresa de este mundial Pero él también
venía diciendo ya si está en estas
instancias del mundial ya no se trata de
una sorpresa es un equipo simplemente
que no hay que subestimar que tiene una
fortaleza increíble sobre todo una
fortaleza defensiva un equipo que sí
eliminó a España que sacó a Portugal en
el último partido y que ahora bien
Podría ponerle un pie encima a Francia
Así que lo que el entrenador francés ha
querido también es Mostrar que no
Francia no se ve como favorita a este
partido sabe que se va va a tener un
enfrentamiento bastante complicado y de
hecho mucho se hablaba acerca de la poca
posesión que tiene Marruecos es el
segundo equipo que menos posesión tiene
en este mundial cerca del 30%, pero que
además también estuvo en conferencia de
prensa él decía sí pero los equipos que
tienen menos posición no quiere decir
que por eso pierdan en la realidad y
finalmente son Pues estaba de acuerdo
con esta posición de su de su homólogo
explicando esto también y ahora digamos
que entre la conferencia de prensa desde
el día de hoy y la de los que tuvimos
del día de ayer de dos de los jugadores
entre ellos Rafael bagán Pues todos
decían no queremos partir como favoritos
no queremos partir tampoco como
subestimando este equipo y simplemente
saben que van a tener que trabajar con
muchísima atención esta defensa
triangular que utiliza cada vez más
regla y que ha sido pues es la es la
base de su fortaleza más allá también no
solamente de su poder ofensivo a pesar
de que no hayan marcado muchos goles
Pero bueno Solo han recibido un gol en
contra que además fue un gol en portería
propia Así que eso también dice mucho
del poderío que puede tener Marruecos
pues Natalia Muchísimas gracias por este
desde Qatar mañana mucho más como
siempre de aquí hasta el final de este
Campeonato del mundo el 18 de diciembre
quiero acabar de nuevo con Octavio
porque ayer hablábamos aquí de
individualidades dentro de estos equipos
francés y marroquíes te quiero preguntar
qué tipo de partido podemos encontrarnos
mañana dadas las el juego que hemos
visto hasta ahora de los dos equipos Yo
supongo Rodrigo que Francia es el equipo
que va a proponer tiene la obligación
tiene la responsabilidad es el equipo
que evidentemente tiene que ir a buscar
el partido con la forma en cómo estaba
jugando los últimos partidos con
griezmann siendo el Baluarte fundamental
de la mitad de la cancha Y con los tres
de arriba los que vaya a colocarte allá
yiru mbappé o o dembelé Y supongo yo que
Marruecos como nos tiene acostumbrados
tratará de de colocarse bien en la zona
defensiva para evitar cualquier error
que le permita facilidad a mbappé o
alguno de los delanteros franceses Y a
partir de ahí generar en velocidad del
contragolpe que te va a permitir tener
la posibilidad de marcar yo me imagino
un partido así uno defendiendo el otro
atacando y Marruecos buscando la
posibilidad histórica de meterse en esa
final frente Argentina Te atreverías a
decir si Marruecos puede dar la sorpresa
mañana yo creo que no yo creo que no yo
creo que hasta aquí llega lo de lo de
Marruecos de todas maneras Me encantaría
que Marruecos llegue a la final y que la
final sea con un equipo que
evidentemente nunca ha jugado una final
de la Copa del Mundo pero yo creo que la
jerarquía de Francia Mañana tiene que
pasar factura y Francia tiene que que
caminar cómodos esa final del domingo lo
que indica la lógica pero ya hemos visto
en este mundial que la lógica no siempre
funciona en el fútbol Muchas gracias de
nuevo un abrazo Rodrigo ya con esto
acabamos este Nuevo Diario del mundial
los invitamos como siempre a
acompañarnos mañana Mientras tanto sigan
con la programación de France 24
[Música]